so what changes after tonight the short
answer is actually not all that much if
you're traveling to or from Europe
everything is pretty much the same
because we're leaving with a deal
you won't need at least six months on
your passport to travel to an EU country
that was the potential No Deal
consequence you can still use the
fast-track
EU lanes airports - you can still drive
in EU so your UK license will cover you
during the transition period which lasts
till the end of the year traveling with
a pet well that is also fine the EU pet
passport scheme will last till the end
of the transition period and if you do
business with the e it's a similar story
no changes till the end of 2020 goods
and services can be traded as normal
because we'll still be part of the
customs union and the single market but
it's you've probably noticed all of this
could change after that transition
period comes to an end what's it changed
- well that depends on the terms of the
new trade deal the government says is it
going to negotiate over the next 11
months but for the time being if you
live work or study in the EU your rights
and those of your family won't change
the EU country where you live should set
up a system for applying for resident
status before the end of the year and if
you're an EU citizen living in the UK
your rights won't change but you will
need to apply to the UK settlement
scheme before the end of the transition
period